this video taken sunday shows taliban
fighters inside afghanistan's
presidential palace
it came as the group took control of
kabul the afghan capital and followed
the taliban's swift seizure of most of
the country
it's an outcome u.s intelligence
officials estimated could happen six
months after the u.s finished
withdrawing its troops from the country
instead it took just over a week
off the presidential palace the truth is
this did unfold more quickly than we had
anticipated
so how did afghanistan get here
it's a year's long story but let's look
at the nine days leading up to couples
capture the ones that sealed the
taliban's takeover
on august 6th after months of expansion
throughout afghanistan's countryside the
taliban seized the capital of a province
along the iranian and pakistani borders
it was the first of the country's 34
provincial capitals to fall an
indication of what was to come
afghanistan is now
at a dangerous turning point
ahead
lies either a genuine peace negotiation
or a tragically
intertwined set of crises the seizure of
the city happened quickly and a resident
told the wall street journal at the time
it had been taken without much of a
fight
in the neighboring helman province
afghan and u.s airstrikes sought to
blunt the taliban's advances and hold
control over key cities
but the taliban's takeover continued it
claimed four more provincial capitals
over the next two days on august 8th it
sees the strategic hub of kunduz all but
eliminating the government's presence in
large swaths of the country's north
videos released by the taliban showed
fighters inside the city's government
buildings
the pace of the group's expansion
concerned afghan and western officials
who said without a forceful
international response the total
collapse of the afghan government could
happen this fall earlier than initially
warned
meanwhile citizens from kunduz and other
provinces claimed by the taliban began
fleeing seeking safety in the nation's
capital kabul
then on august 10th president biden
defended his decision to pull u.s forces
out of the country saying afghan forces
were trained and equipped to fight
they've got to fight for themselves
fight for their nation
but by august 13th the afghan government
had lost about half of the country's
provincial capitals including its second
and third largest cities kandahar and
herat
[Music]
after 20 years of war much of what the
u.s sought to accomplish in afghanistan
crumbled in just one week and many of
the cities were taken without a fight
with afghan soldiers surrendering to the
taliban taking advantage of the group's
promises of amnesty
focus then turned to kabul as the u.s
began deploying thousands of troops to
the city for a diplomatic evacuation
then afghan president ashraf ghani
addressed the nation for the first time
since the taliban's takeover of the
provincial capitals began saying his
priority was to re-mobilize afghan
security forces and defend kabul
foreign
but the next day on august 15th taliban
fighters seized kabul and president
ghani fled abroad leaving the government
in collapse
and by that evening insurgents took the
palace where they were filmed removing
the afghan flag
with kabul's capture nine days after the
first provincial capital fell the
taliban looked to have control over
nearly all of afghanistan
as the taliban moved on kabul u.s troops
airlifted western diplomats and
civilians from the u.s embassy to the
military side of kabul's airport it's a
scene that drew comparisons to the rush
exit from the u.s embassy in vietnam in
1975 a parallel secretary of state
anthony blinken rejected on cnn this is
not saigon we went to afghanistan 20
years ago with one mission and that
mission was to deal with the folks who
attacked us on 9 11 and we have
succeeded in that mission
by the next day thousands of afghans
flocked to kabul's international airport
looking to escape
the airport then became the center of
the chaos in the capital as people were
seen clinging to a u.s air force plane
leaving the city and taliban gunmen
roamed the streets outside
at least eight afghans were killed on
monday at the airport
amid the violence president biden
addressed the u.s again defending his
decision to pull u.s troops out of
afghanistan if anything
the developments of the past week
reinforced that ending u.s military
involvement in afghanistan now
was the right decision
for now however biden has authorized a
temporary deployment of troops to the
country to secure the airport and help
afghan allies evacuate the taliban
meanwhile saw the first challenge to its
rule as hundreds of afghans staged a
protest
fighters dispersed the crowds with
gunfire
[Music]